what's going on guys this is rob and
just as an update
over the course of the next few days i
won't be uploading any videos i'm
actually participating in a dj contest
and that dj contest is going to require
a pretty good chunk of my time
by the end of the week it's supposed to
be finished so it'll be finished before
then probably around wednesday or
thursday
if you guys are interested in hearing it
let me know but once i'm done
i'll get back to uploading videos for
you guys so i apologize for the delay
it's just
i've really been wanting to participate
in this whole dj thing it's a mixed
cloud
contest so i'm i'm really really anxious
for it so
anyway i will catch you guys later peace
you